I coach women to find their true
self-real relationship with God so
that's my passion and I just didn't have
the freedom to do that I need to find
something that's going to give me the
freedom to work on my why my passion and
property is that how many regiments do
you have we've got two and what's the
occupancy rate on them this month we've
just hit 100 occupancy every day if you
don't take a leap of faith you're not
going to see the reward I could work
just as hard doing this and I could make
20 times the income make sure you're
just in that environment environment
just everything how much are you making
on average with all of the stuff that
you're doing in property until seven and
a half grand every month
[Music]
you guys have been a massive asset to
the property Community you're killing it
in property and I want to be I want to
learn all the hacks today how you
package and sell deals how you secure
rent to rent what you say to agents what
you say to landlords and also how you've
managed to systemize your business so
well so firstly thank you Geo and tutu
for coming on winners on a Wednesday
thank you for having us
oh so why don't you talk about why don't
you talk about how you got into property
how did it all start so we were just
like one time and you knocked down I was
just chilling she was like oh is this
guy um Samuel leads and property needs
you know so so we watched we watched a
few consume some of your content on
YouTube to understand and everything and
back then we were just giving our lives
to God as well and I didn't want to go
and find a mentor who didn't know God so
yeah God was that was it for me yeah so
that's what she was sold in that as well
so we then booked onto your one pound
course February last year February yeah
February February last year attended the
rent to rent Revolution I believe yeah
it was yeah we consumed all of that from
the start to the finish and then you
talked about the subs combination of HMO
bootcamp the four day intensive and we I
didn't hesitate we booked onto that
straight away and from then our journey
has just grown that's awesome what were
you doing at the time then were you like
working in normal jobs yeah we were both
in our nine to five so I come from
building surveying and valuation
backgrounds yeah which is great because
I've kind of always been in property to
be honest I'm kind of my dad is a
painter decorated by trade so I've kind
of always grew up around property and
I've always been really interested in it
so yeah for me it was like I knew that
we were going to be in property and I
just knew that was going to happen so
coming across the year the time we did
was like and there's a big difference
isn't there between being like a
property professional and a property
entrepreneur yeah so like my wife for
instance she's a Qs so she's got all
that knowledge and she went to UNI but
then when we met she was like actually I
could work just as hard doing this and I
could make 20 times the income yeah what
were you doing Juju what was your job so
I have a background in marketing and
Consulting so business Consulting
Financial Consulting and Technology
Consulting so that's what I was doing as
a consultant you're basically naturally
a problem solver you're taking someone
is somebody's problem a client's problem
and becoming a solution provider for
them and that's what they pay you for so
that's that's the background and that's
the strength that I brought into our
business you know um and that's what
we've been doing since running business
every problem we face is always what's
the solution behind it not just seeing
it as a problem but seen as an obstacle
what was it about property that what was
the why what was the strongest reason
that made you go right we're going to do
this the first one 100 was leaving
obviously leaving the nine to five
leaving the right way you didn't like it
much no like I just needed the freedom
like I just was craving that freedom to
just do what I want to do in life like
have the freedom to travel but not just
that but also like I'm a life coach as
well like I coach a woman to find
themselves like find their true self
connect with god build a relationship
with God so that's my passion and I just
didn't have the freedom to do that you
know alongside work and so I was
thinking I need to find something that's
going to give me the freedom to work on
my why my passion and property is that
and obviously now that we're full time
like it's brilliant because we have that
freedom now to do what we love and just
working towards like completely
systemizing so yeah it's amazing yeah my
wife's not too far from hers you know um
so a few years ago in 2019 when I went
to Nigeria we were home to visiting
grandparents as well and there was this
little girl that was coming around to
the house and one day I just asked my
mom and dad I said who's this girl who's
the mom who's the dad to this this
little girl my mom told his my cousin so
I spoke to my cousin I said oh where's
the father how are you guys you guys
okay and she was just telling me the
story and um basically when she was
about eight months pregnant with her
daughter her husband passed away and
that really touched my heart because
this little girl she was three at the
time just never going to know a father
figure and I know her mother was
struggling to make ends meet
um and in Africa you have to pay school
fees from Nursery up till to the
university so before I left Nigeria I
said to her you know what quit your job
this was still working full-time at the
time quit your job I will cover expenses
school fees however much you will pay
for for you're being paid for work your
house rent all of it and since January
2020 I've been The Sole Provider to that
little girl I just basically adopted her
like my own little daughter
um and I've just been providing for her
ever since and that was my biggest one
in fact and I'll say to myself if I
could do that with a small salary from a
nine to five once I've become
financially free and I've got my money I
want to do that to more children in
Nigeria more children in Africa kids who
don't have mom and dads and and parents
who just lost uh who are widows or
widowers
um so that was my biggest drive to
wanting to become financially free as
well and similar to what Geo's saying
with work I wasn't waking up
um feeling purposeful with that job you
know I was working for somebody else and
they were filling their pockets and
doing overtime and not getting that paid
now I wake up different
yeah and and also been able to make a
difference having time Freedom being
able to help people exactly that's
awesome
so you joined the academy about how long
ago six months almost a year ago almost
a year ago I remember that when you
first joined the academy if I remember I
might misremember this you're struggling
at first to get a deal over the line
yeah and it was taking ages yeah and you
were like I need to leave my job like
yesterday yeah so yeah what took so long
what was the biggest struggle at the
beginning and what changed oh
um so it was a fact so we were I think
we were doubting ourselves a lot as well
we weren't being consistent in the first
two three months when we joined the
academy
um we wouldn't attend the Monday calls
every Monday we had this excuse that oh
we had to do a lot more things in our
evening on a Monday to uh to not attend
yeah and then one day we just joined we
heard um say you talk about getting her
third one at the time and we're like
what are we doing hard on a second yeah
we don't have any kids yet we just have
a nine to five Mercedes got all those
things and she's already ready yeah so
like we're doing something wrong yeah
we were like every Monday since then we
were just saying yeah whatever it is we
have to do let's just concentrate on
that two hours on a Monday evening we're
attending those calls yeah we've never
had an academy member ever go on all of
the calls throughout their membership
and not be financially free yeah never
happened there's a direct link a
correlation between being on the
accountability Monday night calls and
showing up and success because it gets a
bit awkward to see like if you're new on
the academy first weekend observe nice
second weekend I might call you out yeah
what have you done then in the last week
a month then how much money you made oh
um not nothing yet yeah yeah that gets
awkward after two three four months it's
like you know what just to shut Samuel
up and also the positive peer pressure
everybody else let me just become
financially free and then people will
get off my back yeah yeah and that's
what you need it's like opposite of when
you're in a job and everyone's everyone
wants you to win but they don't want you
to win more than them because if you
become financially free they know that
you'll leave the circle so
subconsciously everyone's holding you
back because when you're in a group of
people that are all financially free all
winners everyone's putting each other up
you can't help but be successful 100
that's something we literally realize
like it's like the Infectious like you
can't the energy of the academy and like
the people we've met and just the
relationships we've formed the
friendships it's like like I always say
this to you I'm like so grateful that we
join and we've met all these people
because we would not be where we are if
we hadn't and like it's just it was just
something that we really needed in our
life the celebrations that we did when
you guys came out I remember you at the
dinner and I think tuji stood up and he
said we just sold there's about three
months we just sold and we only made a
grand or two granddaughter it wasn't a
huge it wasn't a life-changing amount of
money it's like we just sold our first
deal and everybody was like yeah go
crazy
that was amazing that was like the best
sleep we had I know
talk to me about how you found that deal
what was it like what was the deal yeah
so it was a rent to service
accommodation in Reading
um that a management company was already
uh I'm at the management company manages
for the landlord for a few and we had
gone to reading to meet for trying to
get our own rent to rent so I built a
good relationship with that management
company uh in in reading and you know
telling them what we do I basically sold
who I am as a person and tell them what
we do that you know we're new into
property management but we have
knowledge not experience I mean he
really bought into that and he was
saying to me oh you know he manages a
lot large portfolio for landlords um
that International landlords that don't
have um that don't live in the UK um
he's open to working with me
um you know if I've got investors that
want to get into a rental room that we
can manage so I bring the investors and
he would just be the management coming
over this is a great opportunity so he
sent me one property we did our little
due diligence on it um we were actually
at the BR art course when we saw our
first one
um we sat down with Sue sat down with
Tony made sure that the judges was was
Ironclad and then yeah one or two um
Academy members we spoke to on that day
said they were looking for deals uh rent
to rent deals in Reading oh which is
packaged this one and you'll have a look
so we sat down with them walked them
through the numbers
um and they also walked a few Sue and
Tony which was just there yeah yeah and
then they were happy with the whole
thing you know he was there first deal
and I made sure everything was
understood from that side and they were
like yeah happy to put down to three
grand and then they put under three
grand and it was yeah we're just happy
the next day we had the dinner we we
were so good and another great thing as
well is when you're doing business with
Academy members you know that they're
covered you know that they've got a pims
membership you got a pims membership it
means that there's you know there's a
bit a sort of a bit of accountability a
trust there yeah because you can't just
you know there's some people that are
deal selling and they're just selling
junk you know they'll just sell anything
and then the investor might be like hang
on what the heck is this meanwhile that
person's disappeared closed their
business down it happens yeah you know
and you've got to know how to do your
due diligence on the people you do
business with not just people that
you're buying deals from but also that
you're selling deals to you've got to
qualify them you can't just sell to some
random person you've got to qualify them
you know you've got to have contracts in
place yeah you know so now you've gone
on you've been selling on average what
like at least a deal a month yeah yeah
that's the average yeah which has
replaced your salary alone basically and
you've also got rent to rent how many
rent events do you have so we've got two
so we've got one in Windsor one in
Milton Keynes and we're on the way to
getting our third now it's just going
through like referencing and everything
with agents are they rent to HMO or into
service to combination service
accommodations and what's the occupancy
rate on them
people fear sorry but that's something
that's okay people really no fear
getting a rent to rent putting it on
booking.com getting a channel manager
Airbnb and the bookings aren't coming
yeah so be really interested what
percentage you're full Milton Keynes so
this month we've just hit 100 occupancy
wow yeah every day every single day yeah
it was a couple so one thing we've
understood from from service combination
if our guest books 10 nights or more
there's a 90 chance they're going to
extend yeah yeah yeah because they're
they're yeah because if you think this
couple are relocators so if you think if
it's people wanting to stay in a service
accommodation while they're looking for
somewhere to live
they're probably going to want to extend
it if it's not for the whole month at
least for another like week or so we've
now got the strategy of telling them
like oh you can extend and you can book
through our website direct booking and
get 10 off and so that's what they do
and so that's why we've been able to
achieve 100 occupancy I was going to say
it sounds High another thing when people
think about service accommodation they
just think tourists yeah but tourist is
a very small percentage of guests
especially in the place at Milton Keynes
and I remember there was a lady who was
just brand new to the academy lived in
Milton Keynes and she was saying to me
oh obviously it won't work in Milton
Keynes and I said what do you mean
obviously well I said we've got loads of
people doing it Milton Keynes and she
was and she was like but who's going to
want to come to Milton Keynes on holiday
and I was like ah yeah if you're
thinking of it like that yeah Miami
Milton Keynes
if you're thinking of it like that but
if you've got contractors professionals
relocators actually there's a huge
market for it I always say to a lot of
the first time investors or people
taking on a rental service accommodation
50 of it is how you mark
marketing background so pull out the
unique selling point of that property as
they've got a balcony you know like what
about the Futures make it comfortable to
live in you know because a lot of people
get in their minds that oh
um I think they assume that they had
guests you're not your own guests you
know Target Target your top three your
top three guests are they couples are
they families are they tourists or
contractors so your your description and
your title should be aimed towards your
target audience always yeah and your
your top five to ten pictures should be
aimed at your target audience as well so
50 of managing service accommodation by
yourself is how you Market your property
as well so that's something we learned
because in the because we got both rsas
in like winter months like the hardest
time to get them it is so when we first
got them obviously we weren't getting
many bookings we spoke to Academy
members like people who had some in
those areas and also just who had been
had quite a few essays and doing it for
a while asking them how do they Market
it it's looking at their listing seeing
what we were doing wrong that's when we
realized we weren't marketing it right
and so that's when we made the changes
took better pictures like you said
targeted the audiences that we wanted to
Target our Windsor one is like six
minutes from Legoland so obviously we're
targeting families and contractors
because it's near Slough business park
so we started changing our description
to fit around that and so that's how
we've been able to achieve the occupancy
now and we'll make changes every week
because when you make changes every week
something we learned from an academy
member it pushes your property up on the
algorithm yeah on the online travel
agents and then it gets your property
like to the top and it makes it more
popular because you're constantly
changing things and we also have a
Target as well that we aim for we aim
for 70 argumentary every month
everything anything beyond that is a
great bonus for us because we're going
to be making more than we expected well
we always aim for a target of if our
researchers said 70 the average we aim
for that every month and everything on
top of that it's just an extra bonus I
think the best time to get service
accommodation properties is January and
February and I'll tell you why I think
January is the best because if you can
make profit in February yeah right yeah
then you're gonna kill it the rest of
the year and it's I'd be worried if
someone said to me I've just got
property in August I've just got a
property in July and I made 450 quid I'm
like oh oh because if you can only make
450 quid in July and August and
September then you might end up losing
money so you've got to really think
about this as rather than a monthly
thing this is an annual thing yeah um
what what sort of profits are you making
then on your two rental rents generally
so Milton Keynes is making on average
about 500 pounds a month profit yeah
Windsor is Winter's a bit and bit of a
slower one slower burner because there's
more expenses in it
um we've been able to cover like rent
bills which is great we haven't had to
use our own money or anything so that's
obviously a bonus for us
um but we haven't seen like a full
profit from it yet but we're net we're
confident though that in April because
we we're seeing more and more of a
decrease in expenses because we're
getting more bookings and higher nightly
rates yeah yeah so in April we're very
confident that we'll make a good profit
from it so it's been a bit slower but we
know it's going to get this game there
how much are you making on average with
all the stuff that you're doing in
property in total because you quit your
jobs now yeah yeah so what what sort of
what sort of income are you yeah it
makes about seven seven and a half seven
and a half grand every month yeah and
that's for everything yeah so you're
selling and rent to rent and we're
trying to sell on average about three
Deals a month okay yeah yeah so you're
pushing that up now yeah yeah yeah when
the new year started we pushed that
because obviously we're full time now so
and then when we split our rolls I won't
just ham into deal selling and making
sure that we're hitting what are your
roles then Geo and tutu how do you kind
of like manage your the whole business
in in terms of what are your you just do
the same things you're both a bit of
everything well have you got clear
defined roles yeah clear defined roles
yeah so for me I manage our service
accommodations so like I will make sure
everything is fine the guests are fine
guests are checking in and out okay
cleaners are on job like doing what
they're meant to do and making sure
everything is like fine you know if the
service accommodations also doing like
the admin spreadsheets and all of that
you know
um so making sure everything's like
organized and so following makes all the
mess and then you pick up all that I
need to yeah sounds like me and my wife
I'm the uh the Builder she's the manager
yeah that's it yeah yeah yeah I make
sure everything's like behind the scenes
everything's fine and yeah yeah and then
I'm constantly talking to investors
um um yeah speaking with other deal
sources as well I've seen what deals are
up there um qualifying bespoke investors
as well and then going and finding new
deals for them as well so my side of the
business is more the deal setting side
we do have um business meetings at the
end of every day to make sure that you
know we keep each other accountable and
we um at the end of the week we don't
look like we call what's left that we
have that wasn't that isn't priority
that isn't done and then we do all the
admin together as well what would you
say have been in your mistakes then in
in business oh that's a good question
yeah what was our mistakes uh oh
I need to think about it I think we kind
of clashed heads in the first two three
months
um because this is our second business
together so well but this is our first
property business together so the first
three months we were just trying to
figure out how do both both strengths
work you know
um it just it just took a while we were
both like clashing heads of like how we
fall like the business should move
forward and property because we're still
learning different strategies you only
just learn rent to rent and services
commercial the time then we went into
the brass then the lease option
um and then deal selling yeah so just as
we'll learn all the strategies we're
just trying to figure out
you know like where what direction were
you heading with this business you know
um yeah I was trying to sell deals she's
trying to do this be ours nobody was
doing rental ends so um so it was just
yeah just clashing and then when we then
we then sat down and said cool this is
what she's strong now this is what I'm
strong at let's have Claire Define roles
in the business unless let's manage each
other like directors as well yeah that's
the thing and I think that's why it took
because it took us about six seven
months to like get our first well sell
our first deal but also get our first
rent to rent and I think that's actually
a big reason why it took us a while
because we weren't because we were a bit
like oh I wouldn't do this and this and
this I want to do everything and we
didn't have like a streamlined direction
of where we were going yeah
yeah it can it did it took us time and
that's and it's fine but because you
understand our own Journey so yeah it
was fine for us because you understand
our own Journey we're not following or
comparing to everybody else yeah and my
biggest thing I always say is direction
is more important than speed so we're
right in a rush exactly get successful
making sure that we're doing it
diligently and following the footsteps
that you've taught us yeah to get there
now we're here how does it feel Geo be
free from your job now
um like the best feeling ever yeah yeah
it was coming home I was like coming
home I would be like starting at waking
up at like five six a.m start which is
fine if you're doing what you love right
but I wasn't so I was getting up at five
six a.m and it was still dark like
feeling like oh great here we go again
um and then coming home at like 8 P.M
working till 10 P.M to finish like what
I had to do for the day I'd be like
breaking down and crying to him like I
can't do this anymore like it was so a
lot of stress on me and I was like I
just I'm done like I'm just ready to
just walk away and I was saying to God
like God like please I need to get out
of this job and then it happened like a
month after I prayed to him
and so I was like it's just amazing like
yeah how did you justify the decision to
invest into the academy because that's a
big investment I know yeah you had to
convince me yeah she has to convince me
because we had um and I was saying this
to my I think I told a few people this
as well our first two years in together
we've saved up enough money to put a
deposit down in a house yeah oh yeah all
that work for all those Yeah Yeah in our
savings in our savings and after the AC
and HMO boot camp when we first we first
heard about the academy we were like
yeah we're gonna well she said yeah
we're gonna do it yeah and the the
African and me was just like no I refuse
to take half my savings
nah you must be bluffing but um she made
me realize that no it's not money it's
an investment into like the knowledge
you're going to acquire ourselves the
mentoring you're gonna get and so I
bought into that and I believed in her
and I trusted that so took my half as
well put it into the academy and we yeah
we just did it without looking back yeah
wow yeah big commitment yeah it's worth
it
oh yes it's completely propelled us like
I mean for us to be here it's mad like
like I was saying to like we're actually
doing this like yeah just having tea one
night and that's what you're on text
come from we were like
you know Seven Grand a month is serious
yeah it's serious profit to be making
and you know you've both quit your job's
Gone full time and massive asset to the
community as well thank you did a lot of
business with people what were your
final words of wisdom for people that
are maybe just getting started into
property or wanting to get into property
what would you be your best piece of
advice
um for me I would say
work work on your mindset first
it's the most I've realized it's the
most important thing like for me when I
started I was very I suffered a lot of
anxiety
um like yeah it was a big thing for me
and I I realized like for me to succeed
in this I have to push through anxiety
fear fear of judgment fear of rejection
like all of that I had to push through
that I just had to do it and thankfully
I had you he was so supportive through
it pushing me and being alongside me but
I would say first of all like make sure
your mind is in the right place like
make sure you're able to first of all be
vulnerable of people around you surround
yourself with people that are gonna push
you that know you that know maybe where
your mind sometimes goes and can pull
you back you know and that's what I
would say is like the biggest thing is
the mindset and also like I said
Community surround yourself with people
because I get I understand I'm grateful
that we've got each other and I
understand people that are doing on
their own that it can be hard
um so if you're on your own and you're
not around family and friends that
kind of have the same driver mindset as
you like make sure you're surrounding
yourself with people that do make sure
you're just in that environment
environment's just everything so big
time yeah environment is such everything
and yeah for me it's it's
my biggest saying which I I've adopted
is direction is so much more important
than speed
um if you're just starting out and you
don't have the knowledge get some
knowledge you know you went to
University for three or four years or
whatever it is and you got a degree and
now you're paying off on tax just
because you didn't physically put that
money in doesn't mean you're not paying
for it somehow you know so
invest in learning how to do property
correctly and just reach out to put
yourself out there if you don't if you
don't
um take a leap of faith or take take a
risk you're not going to see the reward
but there's risk in everything you know
so you just yeah you just gotta just to
just jump in and and do it and and
believe in yourself like Javon and and
see every no as one step closer to a yes
you know everybody that ever had a job
hasn't gone through a no but that didn't
stop you from getting the job eventually
you had to drive through that no so
every we only through like what 300
knows before we got our first one in our
rental service accommodation so yeah we
we've been through you know so when
people reach out to us saying oh man I
feel down right after two I'm like
well congratulations on your success and
your persistence and uh thanks for
coming on the show thank you thank you
so much for having us yeah
[Music]